How are you feeling now?
Fun Back at work.
What line of work are you in?
Waste Management.
Consultant
gangster is deeply ingrained in American
cinema.
The gun slinging bad asses of the
criminal underworld have had enormous
success since their inception in the
silent era,
but how is it that the American gangster
I character still violent,
profane and cruel.
It's so glorified on the big screen.
I want to explore a cycle analytic
approach to this question and see how
the American gangster embodies and nate
and universal human desires.
Let's start with a simple question.
Who was the original gangster?
Where did this larger than life persona
come from?
With this question,
you run into problems.
I personally consider Rico Band Delo in
Little Caesar to be the first true
gangster,
one of the first talking gangsters.
He's also the first to have the iconic
accent,
indistinct speech role.
Now very familiar with
massage.
A shirt my way out of it,
like a joke for the Naga afterwards.
The promise that he isn't really a
gangster.
He's actually inspired to become a
gangster from a newspaper article about
Pete Montana to try to enter the
gangster world.
He's a copycat.
The very first gangster film is the
musketeers of pig alley,
and the name of the film originates from
a newspaper article about the shooting
of a gambler on quote,
New York's other side.
Perhaps the actual original depiction of
gangsters was in a collection of
photographs of the slums by Jacob Reese
with the famous photo bandits roost in
1890.
The problem with the gangsters genre
begins here.
This photo is staged,
constructed the shot to have its
trademark level of fear and fascination
that we know and love today,
and gangsters and the influence of this
picture on the gangsters genre is seen
up and into the 21st century.
This brings me to my first point.
There is no original gangster.
Pretty much every gangster we know and
love is a copycat.
Michael Corleone,
military uniform and original distaste
for gang life borrows straight from Mike
powers in the public enemy,
and this shot in pulp fiction eludes
directly to the Godfather.
Tommy's erratic behavior in Goodfellas,
echoes cody Jarret in white heat.
Scarface is a remake,
and even the modern hood gangster
doesn't completely depart from
conventional gangsters.
They kept me in the hospital a week or
so.
I mostly stayed up thinking about my
cousin watching old games,
the movies,
some identification.
How about Miami?
This guy,
and of course the sopranos is famous for
referencing multiple gangster movies in
pretty much every episode.
Shimmy up a
what?
I thought I was out
separate buckets.
Every iconic gangster movie is in some
way copycat to make up.
What was your conversation with yourself
about how the violence should be?
I confess that I was very impressed with
Arthur pens,
a Bonnie and Clyde and thought about
that when watching sonny corleone get
shot without a doubt,
and I thought that the effects
of violence and money,
I'd always had an imaginative
and I'd like to think a good fellas
comes out of the tradition of something
as extreme
as the roaring twenties in scarface.
What's important to note here is that
every gangster borrowed something from
older gangsters,
and if you go back far enough,
the gangster isn't based in reality at
all.
There's only the artificially
constructed idea of the gangster.
This is a key point in understanding
American obsession with the gangster.
We're not actually obsessed with being
the leader of the criminal underworld.
We're obsessed with what being a
gangster represents.
Now we have to go back to the question
at hand.
What does it gangster represent and why
do we like them so much?
What does the gangster even if you think
it's just money or women than you're
wrong,
forgetting all about the money and
everything.
The best thing is we can find out what a
gangster wants because they tell us,
I don't want to be a product of my
environment.
I want my environment to be a product of
meat.
So what does that mean?
That line describes the desire that any
human fields and understands if you
watch any gangster movie,
each one has this similar idea.
I don't want to dance around other
people.
They to understand what this idea means.
You have to take a trip into the human
psyche.
I point to a quote from psychologist,
Adam Phillips.
We wouldn't think of anything as a
tragedy if we did not have a deeply
ingrained sense of order already there
to be a frontier when we're angry.
It's because something doesn't happen in
the way we want it to.
Even when you get mad at something as
simple as losing your keys,
it means your fantasy of an ideal world.
A world where everything is available to
you at your fingertips was disrupted in
the ideal life.
The rest of the world revolves entirely
around you.
Would you like to go walking in the
dining room with the donor?
So Dallas,
Dallas,
wearing a nice silk dress?
Never everybody waiting on you do like
it.
The gangster is the perfect embodiment
of this fantasy.
The world operates how the gangster
wants it to operate.
He can give us with the twitch of his
fingers when he walks into a room,
people offering them a place to sit,
to do business.
All he has to do is not disability of
the gangster,
transcends simple money or sex or
respect.
It is the idea that the gangster has
complete dominion over his world.
I want to make them an offer in the
Godfather.
What's the first thing Vito Corleone
asks?
Please come to me first.
In this scene,
America Bonasera acts as a threat to the
gangsters.
All powerful reach bonus here it goes to
the police first showing that he
believes more in the American justice
system than in Beto.
Even the lighting has bonused.
Sarah's face looked like a rat,
making him visually appear like a
trader.
He doesn't buy into the Godfather's
power,
but of course the godfather winds from
over in all of media.
That gangster is perhaps the closest
embodiment to a guy.
Superheros come close,
but even they have to fight villains and
save the world.
Gangsters have nothing to worry about.
The appeal of the gangster is not that
he's a gangster,
it's that he is all knowing and all
powerful.
If he doesn't want to pay the tab,
he doesn't have to imagine being able to
live like that.
I think in the movies,
the worst part about the gangsters.
Downfall isn't the actual death.
It's much worse than that.
It's one of the gangster goes back to
being just like us,
powerless and unable to control his
world.
This idea goes as far back as the public
enemy.
When the very physical and expressive
Tom Powers gets physically restrained
and mummified when he dies,
it's most present in goodfellas.
When Henry Hill goes into witness
protection program,
everybody had their hands out,
everything was for the taking,
and now it's all over and becomes just
like you and me have to wait around like
everyone else and as he closes the door,
we hear the sound of jail,
cell bars closing,
symbolizing his loss of the all powerful
aura of the game.
Of
course,
I haven't mentioned one crucial detail
about the gangster,
the over the top violence houses,
genres so successful with such violence.
In one episode of the Sopranos,
Tony Takes his daughter to visit
colleges on the way he recognized the
rat hudson down and strangles the rat to
death with a wide.
The creators of the show were hesitant
to make this episode because of its
hyper violence,
but made it anyway and it's brutal.
The shots are extremely close up and it
follows the strangling to the bitter
end.
The episode was praised by critics and
went on to win two entities,
which begs the question,
why do we like this horrific violence?
The answer comes from the idea of the
taboo,
something taboo is untouchable and
there's a fascination with things that
cannot be touched.
Subjects like drugs and violence are
taboo,
but the fact that they cannot be touched
gives them a level of power.
If you refuse to touch something and you
have to be at some level obsessed with
it,
if that thing didn't matter to you,
then you wouldn't care if you touched
it.
For some,
the taboo is rooted in superstition.
Mike and Aversion to peg boards or black
magic.
With that obsession comes a desire to
observe the taboo from a distance.
Naturally,
there's a draw to look at something that
holds so much power over us.
I know there are women like my best
friend,
but would've gotten out of bed the
minute that boyfriend gave them a gun to
hide.
I got to admit the truth.
It turned me on.
Speaking of rats in Victorian Society,
they were inexplicably taboo.
They were a symbol of the unclean and
we're certainly untouchable,
but a sociologist at the time wrote
detailed accounts of street performers
who are trained in handling and touching
super rents,
spectators would watch and discuss,
but also wonderment at the performance
ability to put his hand in a cage of
rafts without getting bit.
That performer in many ways had a
mystical power to be able to handle
something that was so taboo and people
in the crowd at something.
They also found so repulsive and doesn't
it sound a lot like the gangster,
don't they have a certain power to do
things?
We would never have the guts to do
ourselves by participating in the taboo,
sex violence and the criminal life.
They have an appeal to them and the
distance between the movie screen and us
is the perfect amount of distance where
we get to observe but not touch the
taboo.
The gangster is certainly a complex
character,
but we're not all that different from.
We all want that respect,
status and controls.
The only difference is we don't have the
guts to do anything about it.
We're satisfied with seeing it on the
big screen and maybe that's a good
thing.
Or maybe
we're all a bunch of suckers and they've
been right all along.
As far back as I can remember,
I always wanted to be a gangster.
No,
I
would only,
uh.